practicing doesn't always have to be
mundane and boring what would you rather
choose
or this
[Music]
okay so maybe you do want to be reading
a book and watching a movie while
practicing but i would personally go
with the second option not only is it
less annoying to listen to it's more
creatively engaging i will get into the
strategy behind how to come up with
something like that
and guess what you're working on the
same thing in both scenarios
what i'm doing is creatively repackaging
my task you can think of it in two parts
number one you have something you need
to repeat in order to have it become
effortless and number two
you repackage it in a way that promotes
repetition in a natural and engaging way
and you can do this by shifting some
notes around recomposing parts of it
adding notes to the end of it so that it
becomes a loop that's more interesting
and fun to play i feel so strongly about
this practice method because it allows
you to repeat something many many times
without getting turned off by it and
that is so important
even if you like this treadmill type of
practicing a lot of times i see
musicians approach it in an overly
athletic way and sometimes this can lead
to injuries because you're likely to be
in a constant state of stress and
tension
and your body is full of adrenaline
let's be honest how many times have you
just mindlessly practiced or maybe you
counted the hours that you're practicing
in a day or the number of repetitions
that you're doing for a passage without
putting much thought into exactly why
you're doing this and how you're
improving what's difficult about it and
putting critical thinking into this
whole process in general
okay so can't you just take the original
left hand
and just repeat it yes you can but then
you're not activating that part of your
brain and your attention that's actively
creating something and that changes the
dynamic of what you're doing so even if
it's just using one cord
[Music]
and you're just switching it up that
makes a difference why not add another
one
[Music]
[Applause]
by doing this not only are you bringing
something original to your practice you
are essentially creating a loop which
makes repetition much more natural and
organic it makes sense to listen to it
over and over again there are so many
different options
[Music]
or if you're into improvisation
improvise over what you need to repeat
[Music]
of course learning music practicing
improving all that it's very complex and
it's not always about the quantity of
work but repetition is at the core of it
because the goal when you're practicing
is to imprint what you're doing so that
you have a deeper understanding of the
music and you're mastering certain
physical movements needed to play it to
use an example
if you're trying to jump over a fence
that is three feet you probably need to
be able to jump over a fence that is
above three feet
in order to handle that fence with ease
okay so now you may be saying i'm not a
pianist i don't have access to two parts
i can't just change the harmony in one
hand
well in that case i would still use this
method because there are ways to change
the nodes slightly or add something to
the end so that you're creating a
natural loop so let's say that you're
working on a phrase like this
[Music]
instead of just repeating it over and
over again
maybe add another measure to the end
which is sort of like a response
[Music]
to me i think this has a more natural
momentum to it which invites repetition
or
i just added these extra notes d and c
in this case
which
act as a harmonic reference so it feels
like
except you're not playing the notes at
the same time so this is very possible
on pretty much any instrument
[Music]
here's another example with this passage
[Music]
you can either repeat it over and over
again or
change the notes in the left hand
so tip for this choose two different
chords or two different notes
experiment with this even if you don't
find something that you really like and
it sounds really good
while you're looking for something you
are practicing
whatever you need to be working on so
you really can't lose
as you're looking for stuff you are
practicing that phrase so that is the
most important part
and again i want to emphasize that you
don't need to know much about music
theory you don't have to be a composer
just literally start with one note
random note and see if it works then
move on to the next and just keep up
this process i assure you it will be a
lot more interesting than just sitting
there
and doing that
by doing this
again it has this natural circular
motion and this momentum that makes it
into this nice loop
what i really want to just emphasize is
that practicing can be a very creative
thing it can be very enjoyable it also
requires problem solving and critical
thinking really i feel so strongly about
it because i come from a place where a
lot of things with piano technique and
music in general didn't come natural to
me so i had to put in my hours and put
in my work and i'm also the type of
person where if i don't find something
interesting i check out immediately so
i've struggled with this and
this type of practice method has been a
game changer for me and i probably would
have quit music if i didn't start
practicing in this way so
i hope this was helpful to you all i
hope you can incorporate it into your
own practice routines let me know in the
comments if you do try it or you've
tried it before
and that is all thank you so much thank
you to my patrons on patreon and i will
see you in the next video
[Music]
just kidding